Google wants to hack our election. Google could well elect the next president.
They have a monopoly on information
on what you know and what I know.
Fight against this threat to our democracy. As the 2020 presidential election heats up,
alarmism over Big Tech's influence on
voters is once again reaching a fever pitch.
Democrats fear the impact of so-called fake newsand Russian bots while Republicans complain of
supposed anti-conservative bias and censorshipon platforms like Google, Twitter, and Facebook.
They all agree on one thing: the federal
government needs more power over online speech.
We will hold social mediaplatforms accountable.
Russia was running all those bots about me.They treat conservatives and Republicans veryunfairly.
It's not right. It'snot fair. It may not be legal.
Republicans have put a spotlight on the claimsof one noted researcher and self-proclaimed proudClinton supporter
to bolster their allegationsof liberal activism by tech companies.
Psychologist Robert Epstein. Dr. Robert Epstein, a Harvard-trained psychologist.
Dr. Epstein, I found your testimony incredibly powerful and incredibly concerning.
Dr. Robert Epstein produced a series of studies that he claims show that search engines and socialmedia companies
manipulate their users to help Democrats.
A former editor-in-chief of PsychologyToday,
Epstein has called Google search engine the most powerful mind control device ever devised.
In 2016, Google search algorithm likely impacted undecided voters in a waythat shifted at least 2.6 million votes
to Hillary Clinton whom I supported. If any headline comes out of this hearing, that should be it.
While Google has called his work nothing more than a poorly constructed conspiracytheory,
Donald Trump cited Epstein's research to explain why he lost the popular vote by nearlythree million votes,
prompting Hillary Clinton to call the work debunked.
Last year, Epstein was invited to testify before Congress by Texas Senator Ted Cruz
to warn of the existential threat that Big Tech poses to democracy.
Democracy as originally conceived cannot surviveBig Tech as currently empowered.
In 2020,  you can bet that all of these companies are goingto go all out. They will have the power to shift15 million votes.
He's been sounding the alarm about what healleges could be even more pervasive interferencein favor of Democrats
in the current election. You have hard evidence thatGoogle is censoring.
And you can back that up? Oh, absolutely.
So I explain this, I told this to Congress, the study that I referred to was irrefutableand no one has been able to disprove him.
But a careful review of Epstein's work reveals that though he has conducted scientifically soundexperiments,
his findings don't fully support the claims that he's been making about the influenceof tech giants on real-world elections.
Election by election, I can actually calculatehow many votes these companies can shift.
A big part of that is what you call the
Search Engine Manipulation Effect or SEME.
So can you just briefly talk about what thatis and how you arrived at your conclusions?
50% of all clicks go to the top two search items.
95% of all clicks go on that first page of searchresults.
So I asked a simple question which is,"If people trust those high-ranking search resultsthat much,
could I use them in an experiment toshift people's opinions about candidates, perhapsmaybe even shift
how they would vote?" I predictedI could probably shift people one way or the other by 2% or 3%. That was my guess.
First experiment Iran, I got a shift of 48% which I didn't believe.
I redid the experiment with a new group.I got a shift of 63% which is enormous.
That's one of the largest behavioraleffects I think ever discovered.
In Epstein's initial lab-based and online
experiments, participants spent up to 15
minutes researching details on a foreign election
they knew nothing about. They used a fake search
engine similar to Google that reordered results to
favor a particular candidate. Then Epstein asked
them how much their opinions of the candidate had
shifted. He called the effect he was measuring the
Search Engine Manipulation Effect or SEME. Biased search results can easily produce
shifts in the opinions and voting
preferences of undecided voters
by up to 80% in some demographic groups.I think when a lot of people hear things like
you can shift 80% of people to a different
candidate, that seems on its face kind of
ridiculous, right? So you observed this
in the laboratory and then you're saying
that we'll see that same shift in the real world.What gives you confidence that that's the case?
I want to be very, very clear on one issuehere. I'm my biggest skeptic. So when I get
a huge number in an experiment showing a lot
of people's opinions just shifted, believe me,
I'm very, very, very skeptical. That's why I
repeat experiments over and over and over again.
I do them in different ways. They are unbelievablenumbers, but they're real. That's the problem.
What I'm asking about is what applicability that
really has to a real-world election in which youhave
millions of other variables that you're
not measuring that could be confounding it and
you have people that are bombarded by all sorts
of news sources that don't just rely on search
ranking to decide their political preferences? In one of those experiments in India, those were
actually real voters right in the middle
of the voting period because voting
goes on for three weeks in India. These are
people being bombarded, as you said, bombarded by
all kinds of sources of influence, but we got an
enormous shift with these real voters. We had in
some demographic groups shifts of 60% or more.That's a very significant result as far as I'm
concerned in how easy it is to change what people
say. How it changes whether or not they vote,
I think that's a totally different question. I asked Aaron Brown, a statistician and former
chief risk manager at the hedge fund AQR Capital
Management, to take a look at Epstein's research.
He says that in experiments of this sort, it's
not hard to manipulate what participants say
and that Epstein is over-extrapolating from
his results. When Epstein ran his online
experiment in India in 2014 on real voters, he
exposed them to biased search engine results
for an average of five minutes and then askedthem how much their opinions had shifted.
Whether that translates to actual changes
in the vote people ultimately cast,
I think there's zero evidence for that. Brown says that participants in this type of
behavioral research often answer in the way
they think the experimenter wants them to
and even if their opinions really do change, by
the time they show up at an actual polling site,
it's likely that all sorts of other factorshave changed their opinions yet again.
The people whose votes you're going to shift
with something as trivial as five minutes on a
biased search engine are going to be the people
whose votes are easiest to shift. They probably
end up being people who aren't voting for one
thing.
So these people are going to shift back and forth 100 times before election dayif they ever get to the polls at all.
And so when he says that he got 60% shifts
among some demographics in that study,
do you think that's a meaningful result thatwe can sort of map on to real elections?
Not at all. You can't assume that that's theonly thing changing people's votes. I mean
that's an absurd assumption. Their algorithm all by itself,
it is already determining the outcomes of closeelections around the world all by itself.
Epstein has used the findings from his Search
Engine Manipulation Effect studies to make bold
claims about real election results. For example,
he asserts that as of 2015, bias in Google's
search alone has been changing upwards of 25% ofthe outcomes of national elections worldwide.
Can you just explain how you
arrived at those numbers from the
experiments that you just talked about?
That's actually pretty simple. We simply
looked at the margins by which national elections
around the world were being won, and it turns out
in national elections especially, the win margin
is often extremely, extremely small. Then we
looked at, again, the SEME research which tells us
what proportion of undecided voters can be shifted
in any given election and just kind of
put the two together. That's where we
came up with this estimate of upwards of 25% of
the national elections in the world as of 2015
were being decided by Google search engine.The logic he just described is just wrong. There's
lots of other things that influence people's
votes. How many change their vote because of what
their spouse thinks, what their friend thinks, an
ad they saw, a book they read, a movie they saw,
an experience they had? What you would have
to show to show that they were actually
influencing elections is you need a controlled
experiment. You'd need actually to see how many
actual votes shifted, not how manypeople reported a shift in opinion.
As evidence that tech companies
can affect voting behavior,
Epstein points to a study run on 61 million
Facebook users on election day in 2010 that tested
the impact of Get Out the Vote messages. I actually measured how many more people got
off their sofas and went and voted. So they
sent it to 60 million people. That caused an
additional 340,000 more people to go vote. But Brown says this fits Epstein's pattern of
emphasizing seemingly large numbers without givingtheir proper context. The Facebook study found
that only one out of five people who said they
voted after seeing the Get Out the Vote message
actually did, and the most effective messagetested increased real voting by just .4%.
It makes Epstein's higher estimates of his effectsseem implausible. So of whatever percentage,
15% or something who said they changed their
mind in this experiment, maybe only 3% of them
voted and maybe only .3% of them actually changed
their vote on the basis. We just have no idea.
But it's going to be much smaller. It's going tobe much smaller than the effect he observed.
That's a very far cry from the numbers that you're
talking about, right? So why do you think that,
when we look at this 60 million person study,
that's happening? Is it the actual turnout to vote
that's so much different orwhat's your take on that?
Actually what that means is that if on
election day in 2016 Mark Zuckerberg
had decided to send out a Go Vote reminder just
to Democrats, number one, no one would haveknown,
and that would have given two Democratsthat day at least 450,000 additional votes.
If you can shift 15 million votes,you can create a 20% win margin.
In response to Brown's criticisms, Epstein
reiterated in an email to Reason that his estimate
that tech companies could shift 15 million votesthis year is "conservative, based on what I know
we can do in our experiments." Though his studies measured shifts in opinion and not voting behavior directly,
Epstein says that research on pollingsuggests that people's stated intentions are
excellent predictors of their votes. Because Facebook had a way of at least
estimating who actually voted, it's much more stronger result. It's one we can have a lot more faith in.
That's not a theoreticalthing based on a sort of chain of logic.
After his SEME experiments, Epstein had to
answer one more critical question before he
could arrive at the number of real votes Googlewas changing. Is the company actually biasing the
information it shows to users? The Google whistleblower has
come out of the shadows. Epstein says the answer is yes,
pointing to leaked documents published by the
conservative activist group Project Veritas and
interviews with ex-employees that allege Google
sometimes does intervene to re-rank search results
or remove content it deems objectionable. We're pushing down the fake news,
we're demoting it, and we are increasingthe authoritative news and promoting it.
I felt that our entire elections systemwas going to be compromised forever.
These companies are absolutely determined tocontrol the outcome of the upcoming election.
The term re-ranking is used in the documents.They use blacklist to either remove content
or demote it. There's a lot of material on whatthey call, within Google, algorithmic fairness.
Algorithmic fairness. So simple example would bemost CEOs in the US are men, in fact white men.
Now if you type CEO into Google and you're lookingat images, you're going to get a mix.
You're going to get some more minorities, some more women
thrown in whether that's representative or not.
You see, they have ways of balancing from their
perspective, balancing content any way they want
to balance it just like I do in my experiments. Tech platforms have often been inconsistent
in explaining how they apply their communityguidelines to remove or limit certain content,
but experts in online search argue the
technology is necessarily complex and
always evolving and several studies haveconcluded that there's no clear evidence
Google biases results for political purposes. Company executives also deny ever doing so.
Dr. Epstein's study, we've investigated.We don't agree with the methodology.
Epstein needed proof they were
doing just that. So in 2016,
he ran a study in which he secretly monitored thesearch results of 95 field agents in 24 states
after they type neutral terms such as Hillary'shealth plan into Google, Bing, and Yahoo.
We had the searches so we could see whether they were biased in any way. We found a pro-Hillary
Clinton bias, and I was a very strong HillaryClinton supporter, in all 10 search positions
on the first page of Google search results, butnot on Bing or Yahoo. That's extremely important.
The fact that we're seeing that bias on Googlebut not the other search engines, that says that,
again for whatever reason, their algorithmsare actually favoring Hillary Clinton.
After measuring the bias, Epstein combinedthese results with the shifts in opinion he
was able to generate in his earlier SEME researchto calculate how many votes Google had supposedly
shifted in real national elections. If there is any kind of favoritism
in search results, we know from the SEMEresearch without any doubt that that will,
in a big election, shift millions of votes. In the weeks leading up to the 2018 election,
bias in Google's search resultsmay have shifted upwards of 78.2
million votes spread across many races. What we're seeing here is actual rigging.
I mean this is not paranoia. Thisis fact. This is rock solid fact.
But Epstein wasn't able to determine the sourceof the bias in his field agent search results
and his monitoring work has been criticizedby other social scientists in part for using
a small number of participants who are unlikelyto be representative of the US electorate.
It's shifting the people who are
vulnerable, who are undecided,
and the shifts are simply enormous. And though his claims focus on undecided voters,
his data on the bias they're exposed to isespecially limited. Of his 95 field agents
in 2016, only 21 identified themselves
as undecided and he didn't determine
the political preferences of others. Isn't that a confounding variable if you
don't know what the political preferences
of people are? Because like you're saying,
one of the big differences between your study
and what Google actually does is that Google has
basically a dossier on every person that has
all of these behaviors and they customize
search results and things to the individual. So
isn't it possible that the people in your group,
they were seeing biased search based on theirown preexisting political preferences?
We would have ways of detecting
that. For example, if that were true,
then we'd expect to see pro-Democrat results
in blue states and pro-Republican results
in red states. If we're seeing pro-Democratresults in both blue and red states-
But so you had 95 people, right? Yes.
You couldn't have had more than like
two or three people in any given state?
Again, I need to emphasize thatthese systems I've set up so far are proof of concept projects.
In 2020,I think there's more at stake here and I think that we want to have numbers that aren't just
statistically valid. We want to have numbers that
are psychologically valid and that means having a
much, much larger number of field agents. What
we need are data, literally millions of pieces
of data coming in every day from a very diversegroup of people whose demographics we know.
Why are you comfortable giving these
number estimates now? Why not just say,
"This is a significant effect. We don't
know what effect it will have in the
real world. We think it'll shift it this way
and we're going to wait to see?" Why do you
give these numbers where you're extrapolatingdirectly from your data to the real world?
I'm very careful when I make extrapolations.
I'm very careful to word things in a way that
I think has integrity. So what I said
in 2016 was that if the level of bias
that we found in the sample we collected, if
that level of bias had been present nationwide,
that would have shifted somewhere between 2.6 and
10.4 million votes to Hillary Clinton. I stand bythat.
I've never said I know that level of biaswas present nationwide. I've never said that.
You testified before this committee
that Google's manipulation of votes
gave at least 2.6 million
additional votes to Hillary
Clinton in the year 2016. Is that correct?
I must correct you. The 2.6 million is a
rock bottom minimum. The range is between 2.6
and 10.4 million depending on how aggressively
they used the techniques that I've beenstudying now for six and a half years.
Again, I'm very careful in the way I word
things because I'm very, very skeptical
about my own work. I think that'swhy my work is pretty solid.
His results are pretty solid and they're veryscientific. Yeah, he overstates some, but mostly
what he does is present them artfully. Aaron Brown says the issue is not Epstein's
experimental design but the fact that hecontinues to repeat numbers that would
only be accurate if the effects he's measuredwere the sole factors influencing voters.
And in the context of all the things that
influence votes, he has not convinced me
that this is a significant one. But Epstein writes that Brown has no idea how powerful new forms of influence can be,
especially influence that people can't see. SEME is an especially dangerous form of influencebecause it is, in effect, subliminal.
The political campaigns, I mean they're doing
all kinds of shenanigans on these platforms and
they're buying ads. So doesn't that
make a difference? And the answer is no,
that makes no difference. All of that is
competitive which is healthy. That's a good thing,
but if the platform itself favors one candidate orparty, you cannot counteract that by any means.
Unlike other forms of attempted online
voter manipulation like political ads,
biased news stories, and even Russian troll
farms, Epstein argues that tech companies'
influence is more insidious since users
assume computer-generated content is neutral
and they can be manipulated repeatedly overlong periods of time without knowing it.
Google can take a 50-50 split among undecided
voters and change it into a 90-10 split with
no one knowing that they have been manipulated. I mean my jaw is open.
But Brown says the world is full of implicit
messaging and unlike in Epstein's research,
studies have shown directly that other
types of unconscious influence can have
a large effect on real voting behavior. You have a top person on the ballot get somewhere
between 1% and 10% more votes than they would
get if you reversed a ballot. There's plenty of
subliminal and implicit messages people get
all the time. You don't need an international
conspiracy or a secret group of technocratsin Silicon Valley to influence elections.
If anyone draws news out of this hearing,
I would encourage you to review very
carefully Dr. Epstein's testimony. Epstein's work is once again gainingtraction
this election cycle as politiciansseek greater control over activity online.
We as a country cannot tolerate
political censorship, blacklisting,
and rigged search results. My executive order calls for new regulations under
Section 230 of the Communications Decency Act. President Trump recently signed an executive order
targeting social media and tasked
the FCC with investigating tech platforms
for violations of Section 230, otherwise
known as the internet's First Amendment.
I think this hearing has underscored theneed for Congress to revisit that.
Nobody wants to see a federal speech policedeciding what is and isn't permissible.
The goal here, Kim, is not to get lessspeech. The goal is to get more speech.
Republicans in Congress have proposedlegislation that would largely eliminate
the speech protections in Section 230,
allowing the government to punish techcompanies
if officials were to deem a user's post
unacceptable and the Department of Justice is
reportedly planning to file a new antitrustcase against Google before the election.
And a step on the line beyondthat is a Teddy Roosevelt step.
And it's not just Republicans agitating for control over online speech.
They behave like monopolists.
They need to be broken apart.
Senate Democrats joined them in a bipartisan
effort to subpoena tech CEOs in advance of theelection,
and numerous prominent Democrats
including Joe Biden and Kamala Harris have
promised further crackdowns on internetplatforms for the content users post.
Section 230 should be revoked immediately.
It should be revoked, number one,
for Zuckerberg and other platforms. That's a pretty foundational law of the modern based internet.
Exactly right and it should berevoked. It should be revoked.
You've also said that there needs to be strictregulation of companies like Google.
What's your case for that? Yes, I used to call for
strict regulation. I've stopped doing that becausewith Google, there is actually a simple solution
to the threats that that particular company
poses, and that is to make their index,
which is the database they use to generate search
results, to make the index into a public commons.
So Google's dominance would disappear. They could
still make lots of money. Big customers would
have to pay maybe to access their index, but the
point is that's a simple solution. That's very,
very light touch regulation. There are things wecan do. The EU has been extremely aggressive.
If the federal government does ever step into regulate, you're not going to like it.
Embattled Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg is
calling for stricter regulation of the web,
including his own company. The irony is that some Big Tech CEOs
actually welcome regulation because they already
have teams of attorneys and lobbyists at their
disposal, but new legal requirements are costlybarriers to entry for upstart competitors.
I'm a big believer in the free market, but we
have to admit when the free market's not working
and it hasn't worked here. I think its inevitablethat there will be some level of regulation.
So would you work with us in terms of
what regulations you think are necessary
in your industry? Absolutely.
Okay. Would you submit to usand propose regulations?
Yes. We should be setting standards not unlike
the Europeans are doing relative to privacy. A study done one year after the EU passed sweeping
regulations in 2018 in the name of protecting
privacy found that Google and Facebook had infact
gained market share. It's a well thought out, crafted piece of legislation.
And you think the Europeans have it right?
I think that they get things right. Recently we had Mark Zuckerberg testifying
before Congress, begging them to regulate him,and the Google CEO doing the same exact thing
which is what always happens with these large companies. They can afford the compliance costs
and it limits their upstart competition. So
why are you confident that these regulations
would not do what they've done withother telecommunications companies?
Well I'm very much afraid that the regulatory
approach will not work at all partly because
the regulations actually get written by the
companies typically. Breaking up Google,
breaking up Facebook, they won't remove these
threats. In fact, they'll really just enrich
the major stockholders, but there's a much
larger issue here which is how could law and
regulation possibly keep up with technology.
That's impossible. Technology moves so rapidly
that I just don't think laws and regulations are
going to be able to protect people. So how do you
protect people longterm moving forward? And the
answer is monitoring systems because monitoring
systems are tech. Tech can keep up with tech. I'm raising funds now to build a much more
comprehensive system in 2020, one that willallow us to catch Big Tech in the act.
This is going to cost morethan $50 million. Yeah.
Epstein is convinced that the influence
he's measuring is just the tip of the iceburg
since tech companies have vast troves
of user-specific data to mine and can use many
other so-called ephemeral effects through search
and video suggestions, answer boxes, news feeds,
and more to target and manipulate votersin the real world on an ongoing basis.
I haven't tried this, but what happens if we hitpeople with five effects at the same time?
Heading into the 2020 vote, Epstein says his
only interest is in free and fair elections,
but his alarmist predictions have aided
politicians' opportunistic efforts to get
Americans to hand them more power over
the internet and to control the free
exchange of ideas online. If any of our Congresspeople
could look at these numbers, they would be stunnedand they would take action. I guarantee it.
I hope that video of this conversationgoes everywhere on Facebook and Google.
Despite the limitations of his research inmeasuring the power of tech companies to influence
election outcomes or whether they're actuallytrying to do so, Epstein continues to speculate
on the number of votes they're shifting, confidentthat his claims haven't gone nearly far enough.
A lot of the social chaos that we see that'sall around us is actually driven by the BigTech companies.
Out of chaos comes order, right?It's going to be their order that's coming.
I think the problem is much bigger than I'vebeen saying it is, and I've been saying it's a
big problem, but I think it's actually much
bigger. So what that tells me is that the
numbers I've been getting over the years which arehigh, they're big numbers, are all too small.